you know some years ago i did a video
on this whole water myth that everyone
needed to drink a certain amount of
water or else they're going to be
dehydrated and it kind of shook up quite
a few people because
everyone knows that eight glasses of
water is like the law you have to drink
at least eight glasses of water because
your body is
mostly water and so that video created a
confusion because when you tell a person
the opposite theory of what they're
basing this concept of water on
it can really put someone into a kind of
a confusion so i wanted to do this video
to give you some
interesting new points on water in
general
in its ability to hydrate your cells
first thing you need to know is
what is hydration
is hydration just water in your cells
actually no it's not
how does that water get into the cell
and out of the cell the water gets in
and out of the cell through little
channels
that
get help with electrolytes
and electrolytes are like these um
electrically charged minerals that in
different concentrations inside and
outside the cell you'll get a flow a
certain flow either going outside the
cell or going inside the cell and so a
truly hydrated cell
has the right amount of
electrolytes inside and outside with the
right amount of fluid and a dehydrated
cell is basically an imbalance of
electrolytes and fluid it's not just a
lack of water
in fact if you drink too much water
you're going to dilute certain
electrolytes and create dehydration in
certain parts of your body there's a
condition called
hyponatremia that means low sodium in
the blood
one cause would be you just drink a lot
of pure water without any salt and now
you diluted this sodium throughout the
cells it's very very dangerous you can
have
inflammation of your brain you can
actually go into a coma so we don't get
hydrated just from water
now on the flip side i'm not against
water i drink water and i think you
should too
but this concept of you know carrying
your gallon jug of water and just
forcing yourself to drink all day long
might not be the wisest thing you can do
especially if you start bypassing the
normal thirst mechanism that our body
was designed to
tell you if you're thirsty or not
when you're not thirsty and you force
your body to drink a lot of water
you can end up in trouble especially if
you exercise
there's an incredible book by this
written by an exercise physiologist
with a lot of research in long distance
runners and even ultra marathon runners
in relationship to hydration and if they
should be drinking just a ton of water
when they're not thirsty they can end up
with low sodium and actually create a
big problem with their health and then
you have a lot of
other fluids that you drink through the
day that can create a diuretic effect
you can actually lose more water and
become dehydrated when you drink things
with caffeine like coffee tea
sodas
anything you drink with caffeine is very
dehydrating and of course alcohol right
if you reflect back on the last time you
drank a lot of alcohol the next morning
you're going to be completely dehydrated
that's why you have a headache that's
why your lips are dry and so alcohol is
a diuretic and it tends to dehydrate you
as well and then what about fruit juice
okay would that be hydrating well here's
the data with glucose let's just take a
diabetic for example
what happens with someone with high
sugar they're peeing a lot they have
urinary frequency
and they're thirsty a lot too so the
more sugar in your blood the more your
body is going to get rid of water and
the more dehydrated you're going to be
and so fruit juices
sodas
things with sugar will greatly dehydrate
you now what's fascinating is that
you have all these electrolyte sport
drinks with added sugar and apparently
the idea is that if you're exercising
you need some sugar to replace the loss
of glucose right when you exercise and
they call this hydration but
is it really hydrating you does
consuming glucose hydrates you
i'm going to tell you it dehydrates you
it pulls water from the cell there is an
interesting study which i'll put down
below it's called the nurses health
study 2 which they did on a certain age
group from 9 to 15. now this study
wasn't about hydration but it was
interesting because
it revealed an unknown consequence of
drinking these
healthy sports drinks
now the study found that if a teenager
or young adult was consuming
at least one soda a day
they would have an extra
pound of weight
and this is what they found and i'm
going to just generalize here
teenagers that consumed
one
soda a day
on a regular basis gained an additional
two pounds of weight whereas those who
consumed at least one
sports drink a day okay
these so-called healthy sports drinks
with electrolytes but with added sugar
gain three and a half pounds of fat
extra on their bodies so the sports
drink produced
more fat than the
sodas now this is probably because the
sports drinks usually come in like 32
ounces and sodas come in a 12 ouncer so
when you look at the label you have to
look at the serving size
and
rarely does anyone just drink one
serving size they drink the whole thing
and there's more serving size in sports
drinks now even when people
are consuming electrolyte powders
many times these electrolyte powders and
electrolyte drinks and i won't mention
any names contain added sugar and some
per serving size contain like 11 grams
of sugar per serving size now there's
four grams of sugar per teaspoon so
that's just under
three teaspoons of sugar for one serving
size okay and we're not talking about
like a whole bottle we're just talking
about one serving size or one of those
little stick packs of electrolytes not
to mention the source of the sugar was
it beet sugar probably it was and most
of the beet sugar in the u.s is
total of gmo with traces of glyphosate
which is an herbicide and even if
they're doing sugarcane unless it's
organic is going to have also traces of
glyphosate so that's on top of the sugar
effect so we have this effect of
drinking more water if you're going to
add electrolytes to it and then you have
the electrolytes with glucose which
basically is going to
stop any ability to burn fat
and the only thing it probably would do
for hydration is if someone had diarrhea
for example there are types of oral
rehydration therapies where they're
adding glucose to minerals
because in the intestine the glucose
will help retain sodium so that's a
different situation than if you're
exercising and trying to be hydrated or
if you're not exercising and trying to
be hydrated to truly hydrate the cell
you need
all the electrolytes you need sodium
potassium chlorides calcium and
magnesium now the professor who wrote
the book waterlogged which i'm going to
put a link down below had some
fascinating information in relationship
to drinking more than what you're
thirsty for you have a thirst mechanism
and some people will say well you know
we don't really know when we're thirsty
we just have to force our body to drink
so much water and that's just the way it
is but
he evaluated tremendous amounts of data
and he looked at studies that weren't
funded by companies like gatorade for
example and he found that even runners
long distance runners when they drink
too much water when they're not thirsty
they get into trouble i think a really
good principle would be to drink when
you're thirsty and don't ever force
yourself to drink
too much okay because you can start to
dilute these electrolytes
now on the flip side if you're prone to
a kidney stone you need to be drinking
at least two and a half liters of fluid
every single day but i would also add
electrolytes to that now are there any
tests that you can do to see if you're
drinking too much water sometimes people
say well check your color of your urine
and it should be clear but i think
there's a better test in fact it's
pretty inexpensive you could buy on
amazon or another platform
these little urine strips that measure
something called specific gravity and
that will give you a good rough estimate
on whether you're slightly dehydrated or
you're really dehydrated or you've
drinking too much water because on this
urine strip that you're going to get
you're going to measure a lot of
different things but specific gravity
measures and compares the density how
concentrated
your urine is
to actual water now water has a specific
gravity or density of one and urine if
it's normal should have a density of 1.0
to 1.030
so if your
urine specific gravity
is low okay and what i mean by low is if
it's less than
1.010
you have mild dehydration so the closer
you are
to the specific gravity of water which
is 1.000
the less electrolytes you have and the
more you need to
take electrolytes or drink less water
so specific gravity kind of tells you
the concentration of particles in your
urine and of course when you drink a lot
of water you dilute that a lot of
electrolytes that you're going to get
will come from your food if you eat
healthy
but also realize there are things that
you're consuming that are depleting your
electrolytes too like refined sugar like
alcohol like the things that i mentioned
that act as a diuretic but this video is
primarily on just drinking
water
there is a situation of drinking too
much water and you need to find the
right amount for you
and so there are a lot of variables if
you're working out it's hot outside and
you have a very high metabolism
man you need to drink a lot of water but
just make sure you drink the
electrolytes with it but for the general
person who doesn't really work out that
much
and it's not summer i would pay
attention to your thirst i would use
that as a guide and try not to force
yourself to drink more than what your
body really should be taking
now i think the best next video for you
to watch would be my video on
electrolytes okay so check it out i put
it right here